hey guys maximum McGee here and a few
weeks back at GDC I had the pleasure of
checking out an early beta version of
totem totem comes from the development
team press play who some of you out
there may recognize as the developers of
max the curse of brotherhood their new
game is also a 2d side-scrolling
platformer but with the added twist that
you control two characters
simultaneously the two characters are
linked at all times so when you say move
to the left they both move to the left
and when you press the jump button hey
they both jump the only other ability
you have is to make your two characters
swap places now while this may not sound
too taxing it's critical for solving the
game's many puzzles as you can see
characters can only pass through
barriers that match their color things
start out pretty simple but quickly ramp
up in complexity as the game makes you
swap places mid jump to avoid obstacles
the game has a cooperative mode as well
in this mode you still control two
characters but they're both the same
color so in this scene one player is
controlling both of the red characters
while the other player is controlling
both of the blues both players must then
work together to guide each other safely
through color specific hazards now in
both modes you probably notice a lot of
orb collecting like that one right there
totem doesn't pressure players with any
sort of time limit but if you want to
get the best score you'll need to
collect all the orbs and not get
yourself killed along the way as each
death will subtract from your final
score developer press play is aiming to
have totem out on xbox one and xbox 360
this fall